foreign
citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to talk about a whole bunch of DC
news that just dropped my goodness John
how are you I'm great how are you I'm
excited doing well thank you for asking
we are on our way to go watch Black Adam
in just a few minutes early screening
this news dropped so once we come back
from that movie I gotta come back here
and edit this so that's why it's getting
to you guys a little bit late we got
some things to discuss before we head
out we got news about Flash we got some
Superman updates we got a minor Wonder
Woman update we got a little James Gunn
update and we also have Batman updates
there's so much to dive into and we're
gonna have to keep this really
bite-sized because we're in a rush right
now to go watch this movie but here we
go let's kick it off with the one that I
feel is probably the most intriguing for
a lot of people it looks like finally
after so long DC is actively working on
developing a follow-up for the Man of
Steel they are seeking screenwriters
right now all of this is being reported
from The Hollywood Reporter by the way
they are developing an actual follow-up
and now we haven't seen Black Adam yet
but I'm sure all you guys have heard the
rumors about a certain someone that
might appear in the Black Adam
post-credits scene seems like Dwayne The
Rock Johnson doesn't give two shits
about letting people know either I'm
only gonna help I guess to watch
interviews with this guy I'm like you're
practically spelling it out man it's
like he's having fun with the audience
it seems very likely that Henry Cavill
is going to make an appearance at the
end of Black Adam so with that in mind
it seems like we are finally getting the
thing that so many of us walk away
disappointed when we're like who's gonna
show me Comic-Con it didn't show up at
Comic-Con I'm excited this is what I've
wanted for Henry Cavill for so long to
get a follow-up to his Man of Steel
films now who the writers might be
that's all up for debate I know at one
point they were thinking maybe getting
Christopher McCory after working them on
Fallout I feel like he'd be a good
writer but if Tom Cruise is involved can
Christopher McCrory really make a good
movie
that's the key is it has to be a Tom
Cruise movie
hey get Tom Cruise to Don the cape you
know no I feel like it's going to be
Henry Cavill I think Dwayne Johnson has
successfully been able to bring back
Henry Cavill and now they're finally
going to proceed forward with it and DC
is saying that that was a great decision
or it might be a Black Adam versus
Superman movie but John how do you feel
I'm excited I mean like as a person who
is kind of in the middle of the Man of
Steel debate seeing people who love it
seeing people who hate it being you know
pretty fond of the movie as of the whole
DCU myself it feels like one of those
unique movie moments where this easily
could not have happened and I think a
lot of people are going to be so pleased
that it seems like it truly now is
happening I can't imagine a Time else
wise where we would have such a Jeopardy
over a roll and then ultimately be paid
off with that actor being able to
reprise and continue on and then uh this
was the other I'm going in order of uh
the thing I found most interesting the
least interesting we just want to mix it
up to keep your audience engaged I don't
have a ton of [ __ ] around updates
from Matt Reeves Batman Universe we know
that he's developing the Penguin series
that's already actively going he's
working on a follow-up for the Batman
too now he's working on more spin-offs
right now it's not just TV show spin-off
some of them are going to be Standalone
movie spin-offs or perhaps you know the
Batman Universe so like Standalone but
you know what I mean and what's being
reported currently in The Hollywood
Reporter is he's looking at characters
like scarecrow which is the one if you
every time someone asks me which Batman
villain should get a standalone film I
always say scarecrow for longest time
I've had a pitch for what I think the
Scarecrow movie should beat Scarecrow
that excites me and especially with Matt
Reeves knowing how to abuse some horror
into anything he pretty much makes I
feel like that would be great looking at
Clayface right now and then an oddball
Choice like Professor Pig so do it
that's the one everyone needs and this
is one of the cool things about a lot of
our comic book characters is the fact
that you know we look at the big
universe dceu MCU but within our own
characters there's a universe that
already exists so I love that they are
building out this bat universe and that
makes it feel easier to separate it as
well from the other parts of the DC
Universe that are clearly more connected
via their films well yeah and even if
the DC EU itself is sort of still
forming its connective tissue I feel
like it makes a lot of sense to do
Batman as its own sort of side Universe
the Rogues Gallery is so rich but also
it's the most steadily established
superhero franchise and the most
steadily established DC franchise so it
makes a lot of sense to use that as a
bedrock and then shoot out and do more
you know Joker type stuff or Penguin
series type stuff or or things that
Embrace stuff that's been working but
that they could easily capitalize
further on yeah I do find it interesting
that this time last year is when DC
fandom took place and they didn't do it
this year and they decided to give us a
bunch of news in October anyway which I
think is great but next on the list we
got got the Flash 2 script is already
written apparently yeah man plead not
guilty let's do this Ezra's gonna be
back that's kind of crazy that the Flash
2 strip is already moving ahead because
you know there's all these talks coming
out about us as we're going to continue
on in the DC Universe or not I mean
that's really up to I feel how people
respond to the movies so people love the
movie and whatever opinion you have
about anything that happened that was
reported on whether you believe that's
real whether you believe that's fake it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter clearly
it makes a lot of money they're gonna
make a sequel and they're gonna put Ezra
in there because there are people who've
come out and said that no no matter what
Ezra's out they have said that but the
fact that they already have a Flash 2
script already done I feel like they
would probably keep Ezra either that or
they've already recast yeah they already
know where they're going next next one
here uh the Wonder Woman three script
mint coming soon all right yeah that's
not a big surprise I don't think that's
a big deal for that for a while yeah I
thought it was already where is it I
thought by now I'd be done yeah the last
bit of news is James gun is working on
at least one more movie for uh at least
one new movie for the DC Universe I mean
The Suicide Squad is like one of the top
like top two for me when it comes to the
DC Universe films Peacemaker loved if
you haven't seen our reactions to It Go
watch it love the hell out of that show
so good and already working on season
two and now James Gunn's gonna be
working on some new DC movie and it's
it's a mystery film like I'm not saying
the movie's a mystery and it's a mystery
as to what this movie is going to be
yeah and I it could be a mystery bill
for all we know he did work on
Scooby-Doo comics
who knows what it might be I mean he's
talked a lot about all kinds of
characters he's want to make even said
at one point he was thinking about doing
a crypto movie but a league of Super
Pets already took care of that for him I
don't know I'm always you say James
Gunn's working on something and I'm
immediately just excited you say James
producing something even if he's not
writing or directing I'm immediately
interested in what it's going to be
because you could always feel his
fingerprints are going to be on it in
some way shape or form oh yeah that's
why they need to get specific about what
it is there's like people will be
satisfied James guns going this is James
Gunn's name get it done so guys it looks
like that we are finally uh getting a
lot of the ball going here now are they
gonna make Robert Pattinson's Batman
part of the you know connected Universe
because I know that's what really wants
to aim for right now and they're gonna
need a Batman they're gonna need a
Batman that does connect because they
are going to want that Justice League
I'm not sure where they're going with
this but I think there are some pretty
cool developments here and of course to
me the most exciting part is finally
they're moving forward with a real
follow-up I mean the article did state
that the JJ Abrams movie that he's
supposed to be producing is still in
development too
but I feel like they're gonna can it I
don't I just feel like it's not gonna
get me I feel like the odds are good
yeah like I don't know how much they're
gonna Embrace else worlds right now I
feel like I don't know as much as
they've been quick to rush into all
sorts of stuff I feel like right now
they're trying to get consistent and
then they will once they've
re-established Henry Cavill as Superman
in a satisfactory way that feels steady
and assured then we might get an
alternate Superman but yeah I could see
it falling through either way man let's
get that Henry Cavill follow up let's go
let's get that Henry Cavill follow-up
all right guys subscribe click that Bell
leave a like but we don't want to leave
you guys without doing it
Ricardo Martinez since this is a DC
related video I typed in on Google
Ricardo DC character and here's what we
get on the prime Earth Here Ricardo is a
long time companion of Danny the street
which is a Doom Patrol character having
accompanied him since he was a cabana
because of this Ricardo has acted as an
ally to the Doom Patrol here are your
abilities Ricardo Martinez yeah you use
a special magical jelly and your own
application technique Ricardo you are
able to heal people with massages that
sounds like a beautiful seductive gift
and man who would have thought we would
have someone so sensual and jesus-like
at the same time at our patreon page
Ricardo we are lucky sons of ducks to
have you man thank you so much for being
a Healer at the reject Nation
[Music]